bienvenue en sûr que je donne dans
l'épisode 4 qui aurait dû être publiée
il ya deux semaines je sais bon voilà je
suis quelqu'un qui aime être en retard
ton carnet pourquoi mon cas mais on est
chez moi on n'est pas à l'école
ça veut dire tu peux nous montrer des
toilettes suivi d'un petit clin d'oeil
de lobber qui veut dire j'ai envie de
savoir où tu poses ton gros tube merde
que les jeux aux gros porc bref voici
mes toilettes
est-ce que ça intéresse quelqu'un
oooh s'en bat les couilles tu peux faire
un temps sur chaque arbre macarons
pendez moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui a
qui voient là est évident sur demande
comme ça je
[Musique]
ce n'était celui qui a posé cette
question de merde voilà ça y est c'est
le bordel qu'est ce que tu ferais si un
mec draguer ta petite amie je suis quand
même quelqu'un de très bien rires un
duel très musclé donc ça me paraît quand
même assez évident et c'est toi qui avec
ma petite amie l'a ouais c'est moi il me
fais pas le malin parce que je te
promets que si tu continues
y'a pas de problème vas-y tu peux y
aller a même fait un nouvel âge tu peux
me rejoindre et si tu as envie moi je
prends pitch est ce que vous voulez
c'est pas de ma faute
zhao petit maigrichon tu peux pas très
fort les ducs l origine parce que tu
vois désert d'italiens et bien écoute ça
tombe bien parce que pareille ses
coordonnées gps courte et intense et on
battait je suis un pur français mais
j'aime beaucoup les pattes et c'est à
peu près le seul plat que chez
correctement la cuisine est désolé de te
décevoir séduit mythes et les pokémon
alors je ne sais pas évité les pokémon
mais un pokémon j'arrête to stop on
arrête hop ça suffit temaru implique tu
faisais des vidéos comment ont-ils réagi
qu'est ce qu'ils ont pensé en regardant
une de tes vidéos regardées sont des
vidéos régulièrement
alors bien évidemment il regarde pas mes
vidéos régulièrement d'ailleurs ce
serait un petit peu blot maintenant ce
qu'ils en ont pensé c'est extrêmement
simple et vous vous en doutez alors tu
aimes bien oui c'est pas mal mais c'est
pas mal du tout et l'api je suis trop
content mon papa est fière de moi j'ai
coutume mais qu'est ce que c'est que
toutes ces vidéos complètement bizarre
mon fils est un dangereux psychopathe
pourquoi tu aurais pu moody dans ton
pseudo youtube a c'est très simple c'est
qu'au moment où j'ai créé ma chaîne
youtube il ya presque trois ans j'étais
dans une team qui s'appelle à eux moody
est simplement sedima durée après deux
semaines ce qui fait que maintenant je
vais pas laisser un monde clan du team
qui a disparu depuis trois ans
j'espère que ça tu as été très utile pas
dans le coup ce tome 3 au début il ya
une des 6 l et après elle s'est
téléporté elle ne s'est pas téléporter
mais s'est passé quelque chose de très
étrange
j'ai peut filmer en caméra cachée je
veux montrer ça tout de suite regardé
vieux voiliers progressé sur le plan de
brie
elle disparaît complètement et en
exclusivité voici ce qui s'est passé
entre ces deux plans
[Musique]
dans les marvel quel est ton personnage
préféré et thomas enders gentils et
méchants compris mme bah écoute c'est
extrêmement simple
faut vraiment qu'on arrête est-ce que ça
serait possible de faire des vidéos avec
toi et comment faire du carton comme toi
comment faire du carton comme toi faire
du carton comment faire du carton c'est
extrêmement simple celle avoir besoin de
deux buts un peu fait un papier de deux
buts un bol en coquille what the fuck
pourquoi d'après le papier vous aimez
d'emile mpenza vous écoutez votre tête
tu prends près un futur rigole tu crois
peut-être que tu seras ailleurs et là tu
fais une grosse taille de rigueur deux
cartons est apparu c'était comment faire
du carton ok désolé de me dire
totalement flashé sur camille d'ailleurs
je mets moi cet imposteur merci de chef
j'ai peur plus chic âge c'est tellement
dur j'ai peur
je
matt est juste le niveau [ __ ] de zoom
wazzamba taf